DUE TO VOTE ON THIS CANNABIS
SANCTUARY PROPOSAL LATER THIS
EVENING.
BRET?
>> Bret: JONATHAN, THANK YOU.
THE NEW HAMPSHIRE WOMAN WHO WON
A HALF BILLION DOLLARS IN THE
LOTTERY IS GETTING HER DAY IN
COURT TO TRY TO KEEP HER
ANONYMITY.
OUR CORRESPONDENT IS NATIONAL
TONIGHT TO TELL US HOW THAT IS
GOING.
>> THIS IS TICKET IS THE MOST
VALUABLE PIECE OF PAPER.
>> SHE PURCHASED HER TICKET AT A
MERRIMACK CONVENIENCE STORE, BUT
BEYOND THAT, WE DO NOT KNOW MUCH
ABOUT THE NEW HAMPSHIRE WOMAN
WHO WON LAST MONTHS ARE ABOUT
JACKPOT, AND THAT IS THE WAY SHE
WANTS TO KEEP IT.
>> HOW DOES THE PROCESS WERE?
>> UNDERAGE ENDO ALIAS, SHE HAS
HIRED LAWYERS AND WENT BEFORE A
JUDGE FIGHTING TO MAINTAIN HER
>> SHE DOESN'T WANT TO BE A
CELEBRITY.
>> THE CENTRAL PROBLEM, SHE
ALREADY SIGNED THE WINNING
TICKET, AS INSTRUCTED ON THE
BACK, A MOVE SHE CALLED "A HUGE
MISTAKE."
AFTER CONTACTING ATTORNEYS, SHE
LEARNED THE ADMINISTRATOR OF A
DESIGNATED TRUST COULD HAVE
SIGNED, MAINTAINING HER PRIVACY
AND POSSIBLY HER SAFETY.
>> THERE IS DOCUMENTED HISTORY
OF PEOPLE GETTING HARMED, PEOPLE
COMING TO THEIR HOMES.
THAT IS A REAL POSSIBILITY.
>> WHITE OUT ISN'T AN OPTION, AS
THE STATE LOTTO COMMISSION SAYS
ANY ALTERATION WOULD INVALIDATE
THE TICKET.
THE INTEGRITY OF THE GAME IS AT
STAKE, THEY SAY, AND THE RULES
CANNOT BE BENT.
>> WE DON'T FEEL THAT WE CAN
CHOOSE WHEN WE FOLLOW THE LAW
AND WHEN WE DON'T.
>> LOTTERY OFFICIALS ACKNOWLEDGE
THE LIFE-CHANGING ASPECT OF
JANE DOE'S WIN AND OFFER THIS
ADVICE.
>> ANYBODY WHO COMES INTO SUDDEN
WEALTH HAS TO LEARN THE ABILITY
TO SAY NO.
>> JANE JANE -- NOW, IT ISU
>> JANE JANE -- NOW, IT ISC
>> JANE JANE -- NOW, IT ISE
>> JANE JANE -- NOW, IT ISR
WHEN THE JUDGE WILL RULE, BUT IN
THE MEANTIME, JANE DOE'S
ATTORNEYS POINT OUT THAT SHE IS